[Musik]
bismarck erst ist die blm juni eine
gewisse einschränkung
also es geht mir jetzt nicht darum also
sowieso nicht darum jetzt die
praktischen wenn sie so wollen auswüchse
des kapitalismus zu attackieren
also die pragmatik oder die politische
pragmatik ist nicht gegenstand von
dieser vorlesung das muss ich halt
ausklammern weil hier geht es um
philosophie nicht um praktische politik
das ist vielleicht eine faule ausrede
aber es ist nun einmal so
ich würde nur als es eingang bemerken
deutschland geht es relativ gut im
augenblick wie wir wissen aus der
geschichte kann sich das schnell ändern
vielleicht nicht in deutschland dann da
dann eben in anderen ländern
die probleme die aus dem soli
fehlgeleiteten kapitalismus entspringen
können sind wahrscheinlich eher
grenzüberschreitender natur also der
politische systeme lassen sich innerhalb
der grenzen eines landes vielleicht
meistens friedlich
jedenfalls in zaum halten
aber es gibt immer wieder klassische
beispiele wo im internationalen bereich
sehr negative entwicklungen entstanden
sind die man sicherlich auch dem
kapitalismus gewissen hinsicht zu
rechnen könnte ein klassisches beispiel
aus der zweiten hälfte des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts war united food in der
karibik diese gesellschaft die
inzwischen chiquita heißt und bananen
vertreibt kennen sie sicherlich damals
united flut hat sehr viel unheil
angerichtet in der karibik an den der
wirtschaft vor ort vor allem an der
ganzen bäuerlichen struktur
das können sie auch in wikipedia
nachlesen
aber das hat auch unter anderem auch zu
diesen diesen aufständen in nicaragua zu
diesen ganzen auseinandersetzungen die
natürlich heute immer noch existieren
also deswegen die ganzen oder könnte man
diese probleme der usa der länder sieht
grenze zu mexiko auch darauf
zurückführen gewissermaßen die sie
wahrscheinlich auch wissen also dass das
der internationale die internationalen
auswüchse des kapitalismus sind ist
schon länger erkannt worden dass das die
schlimmeren cent also linien wladimir
iljitsch lenin der teilweise aus einer
theorien hier nun in münchen entwickelt
hat wie sie wissen hat in seinem hat zu
der damaligen debatte über den
imperialismus beigetragen also es war
nicht nur ihnen sondern auch obst an
andere in seinem seiner schrift
imperialismus als höchstes stadium des
kapitalismus imperialismus neue
kolonialismus oder kolonialismus usw
werden höchstes stadium des kapitalismus
interpretierte schon dann international
und nicht innerhalb der nationalen
grenzen
ok also dass jetzt nur als hintergrund
bemerkung also eine wenn sie sich über
etwas in rüsten wollen gibt es auch im
kleinen ein schönes ein interessantes
beispiel in den letzten tagen
sonntagabend in ttt im deutschen
fernsehen ist schon ein kurzer beitrag
über die insel st im ärmelkanal sack ist
eine kleine insel die gehört irgendwie
niemanden ist nicht teil der eu ist auch
nicht teil des vereinigten königreichs
sondern untersteht direkt der englischen
krone
aber was da passiert ist es ist eine
kleine insel mit vielleicht ein paar
hundert einwohnern und die inselwelt
aufgekauft von zwei industriellen oder
zweifel sagen und kapitalisten nimmt den
barclay brothers industrie der fans also
das ist ein teil der kanal inseln
nördlich der französischen küste sehr
attraktiv für touristen und die barclay
ist mir nicht ganz klar was die bank
dies vorhaben
scheinbar wollen sie dort eine eine
steueroase aufbauen unter anderem aber
dank ist es zu konflikten mit den
einheimischen gekommen
und da haben die bank ließ kurzerhand
sämtliche hotels auf der insel
aufgekauft und geschlossen damit die
einheimischen halt
insofern keine arbeit mehr haben gut ich
weiß jetzt nicht ob das kapitalismus ist
oder oder sonst was aber es ist eine
vignette dessen was schief gehen kann
wenn vielleicht die ordnenden gesetze
fehlen oder wenn wirklich ein
ungebändigter ja wissen falls investor
die komplette kontrolle übernehmen kann
über gut also dass jetzt eine drohte
jetzt ein zweiter punkt auch
gewissermaßen einschränkend oder
feststellen wie ich ihnen ein letztes
mal gesagt habe und vielleicht habe ich
nicht gesagt wie sagst dann jetzt die
die deutschen denker mit denen wir uns
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert beschäftigen
nämlich vor allem aaron habermas aber
auch max weber haben sich vornehmlich
mit einem bestimmten aspekt der des
kapitalismus beschäftigt nämlich mit der
also vornehmlich mit der ideologie also
alle drei waren keine ökonomen lieber
mark webber hat auch noch ein haus und
für die war das interessante problem was
für auswirkungen hat haben politische
systeme und insbesondere
realismus auf bewusstsein strukturen der
menschen
das ist etwas ich jetzt gleich zeigen
will was aus einer bestimmten stroh
morgen auch in marxens werk entspringt
aber eigentlich nicht unbedingt marx
entspricht und auch sicherlich abweicht
von von praktischen sagen wir mal
marxismus selbst zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts also man kann sich fragen
man kann fragen stellen über die art und
weise wie die menschen innerhalb eines
bestimmten politischen systems denken
das ist die eine möglichkeit aber die
grundlegende möglichkeit vielleicht ist
die frage wie kann man die menschen
materiell schutz vor armut und leiden
usw
sofern armut und leiden von dem
politischen system verursacht worden
also es kann sein ich unterstelle
vielleicht ein bisschen bei
gewissermaßen bei allen guten max weber
da waren die verhältnisse in deutschland
auch nicht so toll aber in der
nachkriegszeit hat ist man vielleicht
ein bis sie in der donner und habermas
davon ausgegangen dass das die
wirtschaftlichen probleme die konkreten
wirtschaftlichen probleme vielleicht
doch nicht mehr so vorrangig war und ist
er dann schon um bewusste anfragen ging
ich weiß nicht ich will das jetzt auch
nicht
kinder bewerten oder oder sonstige
werden dazu kommen aber jetzt
ausgangspunkt für heute den nächsten
paar wochen ist die bürger also aus
marxens sich die bürgerliche theorie des
kapitals kapital auch bei marks bei
adorno weniger aber bei allen denkens
bis einschließlich markt ist kapital als
solches etwas gutes ist positiv das ist
eine errungenschaft der neueren
menschlichen gesellschaft und mit dem
kapital lässt sich vieles erreichen was
in älteren gesellschaften im feudalismus
und so weiter nicht erreichbar waren
also kapital ist gut capital ist ein
mittel zum fortschritt zur verbesserung
der lebensverhältnisse und so weiter
also das kapital aus syrien jetzt erst
mal ausgeklammert weiß das ist aber
kapital ist dann was positiv ist
das wird von den bürgerlichen denkens
dann sehr deutlich forciert und
aufgebaut also zu den bürgerlichen
denkens in im rahmen jetzt die
diskussion hier zähle ich wie ich letzte
woche schon erwähnt habe erstens john
lobb im siebzehnten jahrhundert david
jung und alt am smith die beiden
schotten in der zweiten hälfte des 18ten
jahrhunderts und dann sagen wir mal mehr
im 19 jahrhundert dessen kollegen im
selben jahr erschienen ist li maxence
kommunistisches manifest
ok also
hier ist wie gesagt wichtig marx ist
schon eine andere perspektive auf die
auf die sache aber allen gemeinsam ist
der gedanke kapital ist was gut ist wir
brauchen kapital bei marx ist dann ganz
deutlich die frage ja kapital okay aber
wem soll das kapital geringere oder wie
soll man mit das kapital kontrollieren
können aber gut ist es trotzdem
bei den anderen bei den früheren lockt
jungen smith stellt sich diese frage
nicht in der schärfe aber auch
blockierung uns mit haben ganz deutlich
sagen wir mal wer werten
gewissermaßen auch moralische meinungen
zu dem was sie beschreiben also es ist
nicht so dass die bürgerlichen nur
zynische profitmaximierung sind ohne
rücksicht auf bedürfnisse und leiden der
menschheit das ist es ganz und gar nicht
es ist mehr dass die bürgerlichen denker
hier eine andere interpretation der
notwendigkeiten haben als damals wobei
natürlich ist acht marx ja aus einer
historisch aus
gewissermaßen anderen perspektive
betrachter ist okay also erstmal jetzt
zu diesen zu diesen thesen erstens lockt
der philosoph john lockes schreibt also
1690 seine trittins ist überdreht und
gabmann taktrate über die regierung das
erste tat es nicht sehr interessanter
geht es um das eigenartige debatte mit
einem einem einem zeitgenossen das
zweite traktat ist aber sehr wichtig und
da geht es um loks versuch die
grundsätzlichen strukturen einer
kapitalbezogene gesellschaft zu
schreiben
ok und das sind einige punkte die uns
sehr vertraut sind immer noch vertraut
vermerks gewissermaßen alles gut
glaubenssätze des des bürgertums
relativiert aber trotzdem in dem sinne
dass man das nicht dass wir jetzt
überholt sind und dass sie gewissermaßen
bei marx aufgehoben werden sollen in
einer jurist rechtssystem also bei lok
übrigens die texte die ich zitiere jetzt
vielleicht ein exkurs
ich werde jetzt aus diversen texten
zitieren die texte habe ich auch die
website gesetzt sind
sorry auf englisch glaube ist es besser
man geht von der ursprünglichen sprache
raus aber
es gibt für all diese texte
übersetzungen größtenteils gratis im
internet
der zweite punkt 6 kursmäßig also wenn
sie arbeiten schreiben
vielleicht wissen sie das oder so machen
so ohnehin aber ich würde dann sehr
dezidiert empfehlen das ist dass sie die
texte die aussagen von philosophen deren
werke sie analysieren oder mit denen
sich auseinandersetzen dass sie diese
aussagen als quasi als tragende pfeiler
diskussionen verwenden egal ob sie jetzt
einer meinung sind oder nicht wie ich
letzte woche sagte dass es darum geht es
zunächst mal nicht aber sie brauchen
eine strukturelle sie brauchen die weise
texte sind beweise sie wollen der weißen
nachweisen dass der philosoph oder die
philosophie der philosoph in diesem
zusammenhang etwas behauptet hat ja
dafür brauchen wir die aussagen
und sie gehen sollten also meine
empfehlung ganz genau akribisch
theologisch mit diesen aussagen um auch
ein grund warum man lieber die
originalsprache verwendet wenn es geht
und hangeln sich quasi von einer aussage
eine beweisstück zum nächsten
und genau so würde ich es ihnen jetzt
versuchen vorzumachen
ich will doch nichts unterstellen ich
will ihnen nicht mit
welchen von anderswoher geholten
kriterien in der bewährten kritisieren
sondern ich erst mal nur feststellen was
er gesagt hat also zweite in seinem
zweiten traktat wie gesagt die frage die
die frage letzthin für ihn ist wo
entsteht privateigentum des
privateigentums weil das ist etwas was
aus dem feudalismus nicht zwangsläufig
sicher gibt also der feudale gedanke
ebenfalls unterstellt bei lok das jetzt
auch ohne weiteres gilt weiß ich nicht
aber das ist jetzt nicht der punkt der
punkt ist das was sie lockt hier
behaupten dass lok sicht ist der feudale
gedanke dass jeder mensch einen status
hat aber das eigentum da sekundär ist
also der adelige oder könig hat sehr
viel eigentum gehört einiger weniger die
kirche hat eigentum und so weiter und
wird aber das ist eine sekundäre
hauptsächlich der hauptsache ist der
status also der der mensch ist ist ein
geboren in einen status einstand und das
ist dann maßgeblich für seine für alles
andere einschließlich eigentum
ok also das ist das feudale davon lockt
weg kommt es wegen sagte erstens alle
menschen sind frei und gleich geboren
ja du schon also 1690 nicht mehr so sehr
nahe aber trotzdem nicht ein wichtiger
ausgangspunkt nicht mit den feudalismus
vereinbar weil wie gesagt für den
feudalismus oder für ein standesdenken
sind freiheit und gleichheit gar nicht
so wichtig also die bögen sich irgendwie
oder teilweise ergeben aber gleiche
freiheit gleichermaßen ist definitiv
nicht eines stand des denkens also
freiheit frieden im pre modernen denkens
ist nur die berechtigung etwas
bestimmtes zu tun
das ist dann die ältere auffassung von
freiheit und das bezieht sich dann auf
den status des fracks ist also wie
gesagt wenn ein anleger ist hat er mehr
freiheiten als wenn man ein landarbeiter
ist okay das ist die ältere version aber
lockt sagt alle sind ein geboren in
einem erstaunlichen stand zu stand von
freiheit und gleichheit
das ist dann ja so ein bisschen radikal
ich meine 1690 das ist das ende des 17
jahrhunderts in england das geprägt war
durch die den bürgerkrieg zwischen den
realisten und und im republik kann also
die den könig enthauptet haben
also das ist der gewissermaßen
hintergrund die protagonisten das
kommende aus also gegen den könig hatten
schon längst freiheit und gleichheit
propagiert aber hier wird es zu einem
teil eines eine theorie der der
gesellschaft die schon neu ist aber vor
allem sehr einflussreich ok also
freiheit und gleichheit als
ausgangspunkt dann ist die frage wo
kommt dann eigentum her und blogs these
ist eigentum ergibt sich zunächst mal
daraus dass der mensch arbeitet da ist
es jetzt der weitere punkte hinzu kommt
alle menschen sind frei und gleich und
wie eignen sich diese menschen eigentum
an
dadurch dass sie daran arbeiten und
diese dieser ist eigentum ist quasi eine
ergibt sich folgender maßen also jeder
besitzt einen eigenen körper als
eigentum also das ist auch realistisch
nicht selbstverständlich also leib
eigentum ist wenig eigentum eines
anderen bin aber jetzt nach dieser
bürgerlich-liberalen auffassung ist
jeder frei und gleich und deswegen
gerade auch deswegen hat jeder eigentum
am eigenen körper
ok und das weitere ist der nächste
argumentative schritt ist dass dieser
mensch mit seinem körper arbeitet und
alles woran er oder sie arbeitet und aus
dem naturzustand herausnimmt durch
arbeit gehört ihm dann ist das nature
has provided als mixed ist labels von jd
salinger ist hieß es
denn werber mexikos problem also arbeit
ist das was aus diesem natur stuhl
zustand heraus elemente der natur in
eine andere in ein anderes sein versetzt
das ist arbeit arbeit beispielsweise es
kann aus wenn ich äpfel ernte oder oder
wild erlegen oder sonst was das ist
alles arbeit und durch dieses diese
arbeit meines körpers eigene ich mir die
die früchte der erde an was okay und das
ist dann das darf ich dann gegenüber
anderen verteidigen also das gehört mir
genauso wie mein eigener körper mir
gehört für lok ist arbeit dieses körpers
das instrument mit dem eigentum
im weiteren sinne begründen kann okay
ist auch gut so zu sagen ich meine das
ist das ist auch diese dieser liberale
einstellung arbeit als arbeit als quelle
des eigentums dann kommt aber eine
einschränkung also nicht alles ich kann
nicht einfach sagen wir alles was
irgendwie berühre oder woran ich
irgendwie arbeiter oder sonst was das
gehört mir automatisch so ist es nicht
und und beschränkt sich zunächst mal
darauf solche gegenstände die ich
erarbeite
also erstens erarbeitet zweitens aber
die ich auch wirklich tatsächlich
gebrauchen kann und die nicht verderben
sobald etwas zu derbe verdirbt gehört
mir nicht mehr weil ich nichts draus
machen kann
also ich ernte irgendwelche äpfel äpfel
verfaulen
es macht keinen sinn mehr diese app als
mein eigentum zu bezeichnen
es sei denn ich kann auch mit faulen
äpfeln was machen aber angenommen ich
kann das licht als sie sind nicht mehr
gegenstand oder potenzielle gegenstände
von weiter arbeit dann hören sie mir
nicht mehr und gleichermaßen
ich kann nicht sagen ja ich hier stehe
ich mitten im wald und er liege ein paar
hirscher und deswegen gehört mir der
ganze wald das auch nicht also nur das
was sie im engen
rahmen um mich herum von mir nutzbar ist
ist mein eigentum ist das ist der
ausgangspunkt
aber dann steht lockt natürlich vor der
frage wie kann ich eigentum im etwas
erweiterten sinne begründen weil es eine
radikale wie man wenn man so will
kommunismus das hatte man schon in der
englischen revolution und ist jetzt
nicht mehr ganz überzeugender glaubhaft
jetzt ist die frage die sonne lockt aber
auch ausgangsbasis ist sehr vergleichbar
also die levels beispielsweise levels in
der englischen bürgerkrieg hatten sowas
propagiert alle menschen sind gleich und
so weiter und so fort und arbeite ist
das wichtiger aber wir müssen jetzt
darüber hinaus kommen so lockt oder wir
jedenfalls erklären wie eigentum im
erweiterten sinne möglich sein könnte
also warum weil man eifrig war's labour
and materials to work com
also das heißt arbeit schön und gut aber
ich kann nur dann arbeiten wenn ich
instrumente und rohmaterialien habe also
wenn ich hilfe erledigen will dann
brauche ich ein gewehr oder was so womit
ich das tier dann tatsächlich sächlich
schließen kann
und wenn ich getreide an pflanzen will
dann brauche ich einen flug
und sonstige instrumente und das ist
etwas was nicht unmittelbar natürlich zu
meinen
oder wie man es halt so dass wenn ich
diese gegenstände nicht selber
hergestellt habe dann die kann ich das
eigentum der richtigen also ich muss
irgendwie rechtfertigen dass es dass es
vorne weg was gibt womit ich woran und
robeat ich arbeiten kann und dann sagt
okay also das ist das brauchen wir sonst
haben wir keine adäquate grundlage für
die für unsere für unsere arbeit muss er
jetzt erklären wie das gehen kann und
dann sagt er
und das ist ein bisschen eigenartig aber
dass diese lösung wird dann von seinen
nachfolgern aufgegriffen und auf
interessante art und weise weiter
verarbeitet er sagt also das problem mit
dem unmittelbaren eigentum ist dass es
verdirbt
also die meisten gegenstände also
lebensmittel sowieso und auch andere
instrumente
das womit ich mich umgebe geht kaputt
verdirbt hat keinen bestand
insofern ist es nicht so einfach dass
man das als als als eigentums element
betrachten könnte sonst sagt er es gibt
aber was weiß nicht verdirbt und was
schon einen permanenten bestand hat und
das ist gold und silber also metall
verdirbt nicht oder jedenfalls diese
metallsorten eben vor allem gold ist
sehr beständig und gold also ist nicht
erfasst von dem verbot eine gegenstände
zum eigentum zu machen weil gold
existiert weiter und deswegen sagt er
das argument ist dann es gehört auch zum
urzustand oder zum zur vereinbarung der
menschen ohne dass es notwendig gewesen
wäre dass das eine übergeordnete
übergeordnete autorität dort
interveniert oder dass man das per
gesetz oder sonstwas festlegt gold und
silber also geld sind eigentum und
eigentum das über die grenzen der
unmittelbaren verfügbarkeit hinausgeht
das ist ein argument
das kann man akzeptieren oder nicht
aber das ist loks versuch kapital zu
erklären und zu rechtfertigen
also das argument ist gold und silber
verderben nicht und wir haben uns sagte
es gibt so eine stillschweigende
vereinbarung unter den menschen ohne zur
hilfe ohne dass das irgendeiner
regierung das festgelegt hätte eine
stillschweigende vereinbarung dass gold
und silber dann zum eigentum der
menschen gehören dürfen
und weil man mit gold und silber auch
andere andere sachen kaufen kann ist es
möglich mehr zu besitzen weil es nur das
was in meinem unmittelbaren umfeld
verarbeitet wird und deswegen ist gab
gibt es kapital und es darf kapital
geben
das ist das ist loks argument gold und
silber die existenz von gold und silber
rechtfertigt sozusagen reicht um das
darüber hinausgeht dass der menschen
über das besitzen darf was er selber
verarbeiten können
ok also das ist der aus dieser
ausgangspunkt wie überzeugend das ist
jetzt oder diese lösung mit gold und
silber das ist die leichen andere frage
aber das ist der erste versuch jetzt
kapital als was freies frei schwebendes
zu dessen und vor allem zu rechtfertigen
ja es gibt kapital aus loks sicht weil
es notwendig ist
naja gut was kommt zuerst es ist durch
kapital oder durch geld wird es möglich
die ressourcen einer industrie in
eigentum zu überführen
und es ist gerechtfertigt weil das
notwendig ist damit die menschen
überhaupt ihren zustand verbessern
könnten also die menschen brauchen die
grundlage für eine industrieweit
industrie wird vorausgesetzt als etwas
gut ist aber grundlage und voraussetzung
für die industrie ist eben kapital und
kapital ergibt sich aus gold und silber
und gold und silber als eigentum an gold
und silber ist akzeptabel
warum da haben sich die menschen
ich dachte also weiter als das geht es
nicht aber das ist ebenfalls der weg der
zum kapital führt das jetzt als als
grundlage bei lok als nächstes kommt
jung ist
zehn jahre älter ist das mist oder 20 in
vergisst es jetzt aber jedenfalls beide
mitglieder dieser beteiligt an diesem
dieser schottischen aufklärung und
regierung hat diverse rein also wie
lockt auch ein philosophische texte
geschrieben aber dann auch eine vielzahl
von politischen aufsetzenden in späteren
jahren und bekommt jetzt eine weitere
entwicklung hinzu also bei lok hat
niemanden direkt attackiert also für lok
es ist nur einen versuch zu erklären
oder die freiheit und gleichheit der
menschen zu statuieren und abzuleiten
aus dem begriff der arbeit abzuleiten
einen modernen begriff des eigentums
aber attackieren twitter niemanden
das ändert sich ein bisschen später im
18 jahrhundert er ist uns mit hugh grant
nie gesehen werden mit suisse also es
gibt dann auch gegner in diesem
zusammenhang und das verläuft also
eigentlich jungs aufsatz auf interest
also
über zinsen interest im sinne von zinsen
aus dem jahre 1750 geht es um die
unterscheidung zwischen produktiven und
nicht produktiven menschen jung implizit
attackiert implizit den adel also wie
auch marx festgestellt hat also die
bürger so versucht sich vom adel
abzusetzen oder betrachtet die
föderalistischen eigentumsverhältnisse
als es ihr vereint und das kommt bei ich
jung auch deutlich zum ausdruck
also eben diesen einen aus als über über
über das über über zinsen das wesen
stellte erfolgende folgende prinzipien
auf also das erste ist das und das
gemeinsam auch mit anderen denkern im
achten jahrhundert aber das erste
prinzip ist dass der wert entstammt dem
grund also grund und boden ist der
ursprung von wert- oder jedenfalls die
ursprung ist vielleicht das falsche wort
weil er die outlook glaubt dass arbeit
also das wesentliche ist also arbeit ist
im hintern damit ist im hinblick auf
tausch waren sehr des arbeiters
entscheidende grund und boden aber auch
bodenschätze landwirtschaft auf der
anderen seite boden bodenschätze auf der
anderen
also das wäre aus jungs sich theorie das
sind die rohmaterialien für alles was
wert hat ich meine das ist auch
nachvollziehbar das kann man sich auch
heute feststellen also alle gegen alles
was gegenständlich ist muss tatsächlich
aus dem grund aus grund und boden her
kommen entweder wie gesagt
landwirtschaftlich oder oder
bodenschätze und das ist etwas was dann
hier um auch aus sagt also das was
woraus zuerst ankommt ist die arbeit an
an grund und boden
zum einen also klassisch die die
landarbeiter darüber hinaus auch die
bergarbeiter und so weiter also da kommt
alles her
dann sagte er
also das ist die erste stufe in der
verarbeitung
also nützlich ist das was aus dem boden
kommt zunächst mal ist es ist es nicht
also ich muss arbeiten alles gibt
gewisse natürlich früchte des bodens die
äpfel und so weiter die ich gleich
konsumieren kann aber die meisten sachen
die ich dann in meinem in meinem leben
brauche müssen weiter verarbeitet werden
also ich brauch möbel braucht kleidung
ich brauche häuser auf alles mögliche
und das selbst voraus eine weitere
verarbeitung und deswegen sagt jun
abgesehen von dem land arbeiten
dann und und den grundbesitzern brauche
ich ein netter rang of men also eine
andere regel von menschen die diese
gegenstände verarbeiten dann darüber
hinaus noch eine weitere gruppe die es
möglich macht die verarbeiteten
gegenstände auch auszutauschen und zu
verteilen also für den vertrieb und das
auf der help the origin of merger also
kaufleute da entstehen die kaufleute
also wir hätten die die die arbeiter an
grund und boden
denn die manufakturen die leute die da
die diese erzeugnisse verarbeiten und
dann haben wir die kaufleute und die
kaufleute sind letztendlich die
wichtigsten aus seiner sicht ich meine
arbeit an grund und boden ist er hat die
erste etappe in der wert der wert
erzeugung aber was eigentlich zählt in
einer modernen gesellschaft aus jungs
sind die kaufleute weil erst die
kaufleute es ermöglichen dass die
komplexen strukturen einer modernen
gesellschaft überhaupt entstehen können
ok und das ist etwas also dass kommerz
kommerz ist diese diese errungenschaft
das ist das positive aus dass auf der
negativen seite sagt er ohne kommerz
ohne kaufleute würde der staat
zwangsläufig nur aus den grundbesitzern
bestehen estate masken cisco flip
landete entry dessen vor die galati and
expand maker continue to want verbringen
es ist ein bild ist von dem länder von
der lände john grady produzieren nichts
also die arbeiten sowieso nicht an grund
und boden halt leute die das sie machen
gewissermaßen aber mehr als das machen
sie nicht die lande genie sondern die
verschieden zuständig sie haben die
sicherheit ihres grundbesitzes damit sie
sich verschulden können aber sie
produzieren nichts also sie sind nicht
selber landarbeiter manufaktur
hersteller industriellen sind sind sie
sowieso nicht und erst recht keine
kaufleute sondern ist sind einfach da
und verursachen ausgaben bodyguard and
expand also das ist dieses bild dieses
polemische bild im bürgerturm von dem
format der nichts macht also das ist
sehr charakteristisch für diese schotten
durch jung und auch dann später für
smith dass der adel als zielscheibe
dieser politischen diskussionen gilt und
dass der jetzt abgesehen davon das ist
geschmacklos ist ein herumzusitzen und
schulden anzuhäufen und nichts zu tun
außer teure partys zu feiern das ist
quasi das bild was was hier vermittelt
wird dass der schlimmer aus ihrer sicht
ist es dieses wenn man so wie faulheit
oder inaktivität oder nicht
produktivität dazu führt dass das
kapital
wie entsteht er sagt dann money never
get in touch stoxx wird kein bill and
incest displays tinten ampel ist ein
zweites konto ritt in eidelstedt und
leute bekommen es so läuft das ist jetzt
nicht so wichtig aber der punkt ist das
geld wird nie akkumuliert insel lord
stoxx also stoxx ist jungs begriff für
kapitalstocks ist das heißt vorrat stoxx
ist einerseits vorrat andererseits ist
es auch wertpapiere es ist halt eine
doppelte bedeutung also stoxx ist der
vorrat oder ist die grund die kapital
mäßige voraussetzung für arbeit
ja das sind die strokes weil es nicht
wieder so ins deutsche übersetzt wird
aber ich meine stock ist eine eine
übersetzung ist vorrat
aber wie gesagt es hat diese doppelte
bedeutung vorrat aber auch kapital oder
ja wertpapier stoxx ein scherz sagt man
teilweise immer noch heutzutage also
sherrys anteile an einem geschäft an
einem betrieb stock sanchez in dem in
dem zusammenhang dass das gleiche heute
würde man sagen es im gegensatz zu
schulden darlehen
aber wie auch immer also die stoxx es
geht um die strokes und das der money
never gar dass intel laut stoxx also bei
diesem landbesitzern großgrundbesitzern
kommt das geld nie zusammen zu einem
stock sondern wird einfach herausgegeben
und und edelstahl so das ist eine schöne
angeberei ist das ist der vorwurf
also dass diese diese adeligen tun nicht
mit mit ihrem grund sie hätten zwar
grund und grund könnte man wertvoller
machen und dann investieren und so
weiter und dann aus dem erzeugnissen das
von grund und boden könnte wasser
herstellen und das könnte man dann als
kaufmann im kommerz dann tauschen gegen
andere sachen und das würde dann alles
dazu käme dann geld also der erlös wäre
dann kapital noch mit diesem kapital
also was ich jetzt nicht im eigenen
angeben ausgegeben habe dieses kapital
kann ich dann verwenden als grundlage
für weitere industrielle unternehmen
hatte das ist das ist den jungs ein
brand oder kritikpunkt es ist nicht
unbedingt so dass also wieder weder jung
noch lockt grundsätzlich was dagegen
dass das ist eine klassengesellschaft
ist und dass einige mehr haben als
andere das ist aber ein arme und reiche
gibt das mag alles schon sein dass es
vielleicht akzeptabel aber was nicht
akzeptabel ist es dass die reichen und
dann nichts mit ihrem geld machen
ich meine das ist schon eine evangelisch
lehre das werden ja dann wieder bei max
weber natürlich finden aber das wird
jetzt gerade von von diesem von diesen
englischen protestanten oder deutschen
protestanten verfolgten also das
wesentliche
der grund warum kapital gut ist also ist
zum einen mit kapital kann ich was
machen und zum anderen erfüllt ist die
wesens bestimmung des menschen also nach
diesem nach dieser vorstellung ist der
mensch dazu da um seine talente zu
mehreren zweiter herauszugehen und das
was er hat
zum wohl aller zu vermehren und weil es
absolut nicht akzeptabel ist dass ich
einfach herum faul herum sitzen und das
was ich habe dann verbrauch ohne ohne
ohne rücksicht oder ohne ohne zu
arbeiten also wer nicht arbeitet aus
dieser bürgerlichen sicht hat sich dann
von vornherein verurteilt ok also das
ist jetzt das war jung und und lockt das
wird dann bei smith weil differenziert
weitergeführt dann bei smith ist es
nicht ganz so morales dogmatisch
sozusagen aber auch bei ihm ist dieser
gedanke dass das kapital etwas gutes ist
weil mit kapital durch das bilden von
kapital besteht die möglichkeit die
früchte der arbeit zu erhalten und
weiterzuentwickeln und das ist etwas was
auch mal akzeptiert also kapital ist was
positives war im capital konkretisiert
sich ist der niederschlag der arbeit der
menschen und das wollen wir erhalten
das ist nicht etwas was was sie ablehnen
sollten also wie gesagt das ist das ist
schon vielleicht eine etwas
calvinistische einstellung aber
jedenfalls wird es positiv bewertet von
aldi von diesen bürgerlichen denkens und
dann auch von marx okay ich würde
ich mache ganz kurz noch ein paar
bemerkungen wales war vielleicht noch
zeit haben also bei smith where the
nation's das ist dann 1776 bis 20 jahre
später als jungen
diese ganzen gedanken werden da von ihm
aufgenommen und fortgeführt
grundsätzlich auch bei jeder hat
eigentum an den erzeugnissen seiner
eigenen arbeit also arbeit ist dass das
jenige was rechtfertigen ist für
eigentum und die quelle der des wertes
des tauschs wertes ist die property
brimanis in hessen label foundation ist
heilig und unanfechtbar was ich mir
erwartet er arbeit ist mein heiliges
eigenes bringt ok also das hat er schon
bei block gleichheit interpretiert er
ein bisschen anders
also nicht in dem sinne so quasi
sozialist revolutionären sinne wir sind
alle menschen sind gleich eine
französische revolution und so weiter
das ist bei ist jetzt ein bisschen
anders er sagt das wird als als
ununterscheidbarkeit der natürlichen
eigenschaften interpretiert das heißt
erst als alle menschen sind gleich in
dem sinne dass eben mehr oder weniger
alles jeder kann also was was wesentlich
ist das irgendwie erheblich ist kann
können alle menschen das gleiche sagt
der unterschied zwischen dem
straßenkehrer
und dem philosophen ist zumindest in der
kindheit nicht existent es sind
unterschiedliche geschicklichkeit die
die menschen erwärmt
es ist nicht so dass der philosophen das
ist übrigens ein beispiel es ist nicht
so dass das der führer so von vornherein
abend ein genie wäre oder sonstwas oder
jedenfalls nicht in einem sinne das
wirtschaftlich interessant wäre
und das gleiche gilt umgekehrt für den
straßenkehrer alle menschen sind ebenso
im hinblick auf ihre fähigkeiten von
vornherein gleicht erster punkt zweiter
punkt das was den menschen in der
modernen gesellschaft auszeichnet ist
die fähigkeit verträge zu schließen oder
etwas eingeschränkt die welt die
möglichkeit zu tauschen
die möglichkeit des austausches ist das
was die menschheit auszeichnet tiere
haben das nicht aber ich kann mit
anderen menschen vereinbaren
ich geb dir das und du gibst mir dies
jenes ja doch gut ds also diese
grundlage der des verkaufs recht sagt
smid ist etwas was der mensch hat und
kein anderes wesen und da haben wir
diese beiden
elemente also gleichheit der fähigkeiten
bei der möglichkeit zum tauschen
und das führt dann zu seinem zudem zu
seiner ganz wichtigen these nämlich über
die arbeitsverteilung also durch die
weiß was man was jeder mensch mit den
anderen tauscht ist das was er oder sie
erarbeitet und weil jedes die arbeit von
jedem grundsätzlich vergleichbar ist
[Musik]
besteht die möglichkeit dass dieser
tausch stattfindet und dieser dieser
tausch ist dann das wesentliche für das
was jungs schon vorher als kommerz
beschrieben hatte die zirkulation von
werten in der gesellschaft verläuft auf
der basis des und das was jeder mensch
erzeugt etwas wertvolles oder kann weil
jeder mensch wesentlichen die gleichen
fähigkeiten hat natürlich differenzieren
die sich im laufe des lebens aber
grundsätzlich kann trägt jeder was bei
und zweitens die möglichkeit zum
tauschen was die vergleicht
vergleichbarkeit der erzeugnisse des
jedes einzelnen begründet etabliert und
ermöglicht und wenn man das halt diese
zirkulation von werten hat man somit
oder kann oder erst dann kann man diese
stoxx ausbauen
er sagt den common stock das ist etwas
was woran man erkennt dass der mensch
anders ist als die tiere weil die tiere
haben keine kommen stoxx aber die
menschheit hat kommen stoxx die haben
erzeugnis angesammelt zusammen
zusammengeführt und zur verfügung zur
gemeinsamen verfügung gestellt und das
sind die common stock ja also das ist es
was aus dies aus dem der
austauschbarkeit der beiträge der
menschen entstehen kann
ja okay also das ist eine grundlage von
dem tv-sender labour arbeitsteilung die
im restlichen werk ganz eine ganz
wesentliche rolle spielt ok also das
sind quasi die die ersten elemente der
bürgerlichen theorie des kapitals
nächste woche bin ich ein bisschen mehr
zu sagen und dann geht es weiter mit den
kritikern okay gibt es tagen einwände